we both have met quite often the last
days and weeks and uh we have found
much more uh the last time we met was in
brussels in nato and g7 and i'm very
happy that we now have the chance to
discuss together here
this
it is good and important to exchange
views in the current situation and i'm
particularly delighted that we can have
this exchange here today in london
personally and not have to rely on uh
telephone or vtcs uh amongst the g7 and
and the many other formats and meetings
that we're having
and it's good progress that we meet here
um germany and the uk are long-standing
allies and partners and we will remain
and continue to be that although our
friends have decided a while ago to not
be part of the european union anymore
the uk and germany are close allies
also when it comes to the challenges and
tasks ahead
it is with horror and indignation that
we both are looking towards the east
these days and weeks we're looking to
russia's illegal attack on ukraine this
war is devastating it inflicts death in
father mobile suffering and terrible
destruction on ukraine the images from
bucha maria pool in other places
the dramatic attack that we have uh
learned about today all of this is
shocking indeed and
it has to be said clearly it is
atrocious it is an atrocious war that
inflinks terrible
destruction
and inflicts
has many evicting victims
in ukraine killing civilians is a war
crime and the russian president bears
responsibility for these war crimes
boris johnson and i absolutely share
this assessment and we see ourselves in
complete agreement with large parts of
the international community for which
law and moral principles continue to pee
the yardstick this is why we support
ukraine actively with all the options
that we have in the civilian sector
germany is the largest bilateral donor
since 2014 and after the russian attack
on ukraine germany revised its
decade-long position and for the first
time sent weapons and military goods to
a war zone and we continue to supply
arms to ukraine we do this together and
we um actually exchange views on this in
order to bolster the defense of ukraine
against the russian invasions
and of course we need to do everything
in order to stop the senseless killing
and this is why call upon russia again
to finally agree to a ceasefire and to
withdraw its troops
we absolutely need to allow for
humanitarian access and
open safe corridors for people who want
to
leave and
we mustn't see military actions and have
bombings on refugees time and again this
war needs to stop
immediately a pivotal
and central element of our strategy is
to impose drastic costs
on russia for this war of aggression and
this is why it is right
that we have agreed in all the
structures that we are part of um to
impose sanctions that holds true for the
g7 we also talked about this in the
various phone calls that we had we other
partners together and we discussed this
within the framework of nato
finance industry we impose sanctions on
the financial sector on the financial on
the russian central bank an
extraordinary process that
we haven't
done
something that is unprecedented i'm
talking about sanctions on the russian
economy and these sanctions are highly
effective because indeed russia is
dependent on
imports in the field of technology
russia cannot replace these elsewhere in
the global markets and
europe and north america and japan south
korea many countries
that
gather as democratic states are those
who
have the best and the most
sophisticated technologies and of course
it is also important to affect and hit
the inner circle of the president and
the oligarchs and i explicitly want to
state this in london as well and i'm
grateful that the sanctions were widened
on many persons that are part of this
circle of people we have just accepted
and adopted a fifth uh sanctions package
within the european union
we're not going to import coal anymore
and um i'd like to use this opportunity
to clearly state germany is already
starting to
wean off its dependence
and we're diversifying um our sources we
are investing large scale
in order to establish the technical and
physical infrastructure that are
necessary in order to import gas via the
northern german shores
and we are also going to
make sure with legal measures that
there are no
legal difficulties but that we can
implement
our decisions quickly we have imposed
sanctions on the banking sector we hit
oligarchs and we're going to continue
to work in this
regard unity is crucial the unity of the
european union the g7 the unity of nato
the transatlantic unity all of this is
essential and putin did not expect this
he was certain that we would disagree
and he had to witness our unity and he
will
continue to experience our unity
one of the terrible consequences of this
terrible war is
the fact that
a large number of people had to leave
the country millions of people had to
flee ukraine many countries in europe
have
hosted
refugees in particular those along the
borders poland for instance or slovakia
hungary bulgaria romania and we are very
grateful to these countries we know that
further countries such as the czech
republic austria have hosted and
received large numbers and germany is
part of these countries as well
the
biggest share of refugees has reached
poland more than 2 million we have more
than 300 000 refugees in germany and
this is why we're happy and grateful if
many countries would practically
participate in hosting refugees because
this will be a major task and challenge
ahead
we don't know how refugee movements will
evolve
we're seeing a different type of
migration now than in other years we
have
women and children the elderly many um
people who are sick and disabled
and need our support we will shoulder
this together but against the backdrop
of the developments in
this world we can't predict how many
will follow whether these families are
able to return or whether the men are
going to follow
we cannot predict this
at present but what we can say now is
that we stand in solidarity that we
want to lend support to those who seek
refuge and we talked about this as well
and the uk also wants to lend a
contribution to this effort
boris mentioned it we are going to
intensify our cooperation on all levels
we're going to have government
consultations an established
consultation we're going to begin
and hosting a cabinet meeting to the
beginning at the beginning of the next
year our foreign ministers are going to
resume and continue their strategic
dialogue
there are many challenges and
topics at hand
topics related to the conflict in
ukraine matters pertaining to
defense and security pertaining to
climate people-to-people exchange
mobility and i mentioned it as well uh
questions pertaining to migration
we want to make progress um and
intensify relations between our two
countries we can build upon about a
long-standing friendship but this is
what's important here we both
share
the conviction that our relations are
good when they don't only exist between
the two of us the heads of state but
when they're also
um when they exist between the people